um hi everyone uh thanks for joining us
today at the business
value of design forum i'm mark
executive director of design singapore
council and i'm here today with ben
shepard
a partner at mckinsey and company and
the leader of mckinsey's global design
research group ben through your research
you managed to link specific design
practices to a company's improved
financial performance
could you share more about what prompted
this undertaking
happy to mark and uh happy new year to
everyone this is so great to have you
with us today
the reason we we we undertook this
research was
was relatively straightforward we had a
number of ceos from singapore but in
many other nations as well
who were frustrated they were frustrated
that they had spent
hundreds of millions in some cases
billions on
design development and launching
products and services
only to be told by the market that they
were undifferentiated
that they weren't leading to growth that
they weren't delighting customers
so the question that we received is what
can we do as organizations
to increase our chance of making let's
call it the iphone of ours respective
industry that doesn't matter whether
you're in banking or retail or even
mining
what can we do to make products and
services that stand out from the
competition
delight customers and drive growth
so that in a nutshell is why we decided
to do it
the way we did it was to look into the
fates and fortunes of 300 publicly
listed companies
over a five-year period and we were
interested in two things about those
companies
on the one hand their financial
performance how are they doing in terms
of revenue shareholder return and the
like
the other thing that we were interested
in was the design
actions that those companies were taking
and an example of a design
action might be hiring a chief design
officer or changing management
incentives to tie to customer
satisfaction or hiring a larger number
of designers or engineers just to name a
few
we ended up tracking 110 000
unique actions that these companies took
related to design
and the exam question uh was well is
there any correlation
between those who are consistently
performing best in terms of design
actions
and consistently performing best
financially well spoiler alert the
answer is yes
otherwise mark and i would not be having
this conversation today
but we we were surprised by the level
of correlation this graph here uh
what this shows is that for the
companies who consistently perform best
in terms of uh their design actions
they were growing their revenues at
almost twice the rate of their industry
peers
and on the shareholder return side it
was pretty stark as well
70 higher shareholder return growth
than their industry peers that's what
this is about
and that's why we take this topic now so
seriously
it's wonderful that mackenzie has
actually undertaken this research and
managed to concretely actually link
design to better business
outcomes at design singapore we also see
good design practices
such as a focus on customer experience
and quick prototyping and iteration
as a cornerstone to actually helping
organizations
drive a more agile and innovative
culture
your research has actually established
that design is not something
vague or amorphous right it's actually
something that would deliver better
business performance
if companies take actually concrete
steps towards
embedding that deeply within the
organizations so what do you think is
actually critical for companies to
become top performers
and design and reap the financial
rewards that come with it
yeah that's the exciting bit what what
do you have to do what's the magic
recipe mark to uh to start making better
products and services
firstly i should say one's definition of
design matters it's one of those words
like um
strategy or big data that seems to mean
different things to different people
the companies who were treating design
most effectively
understood that the modern definition is
understanding user needs
and then creating solutions to meet
those needs so that means it can be
digital design physical design
service design but i want to say that up
front because i think there are still
there's some people who think of design
as being color material finish and it's
it's far from from that once you've
understood it
out of 000 design actions that were
taken
there's actually remarkably few that
consistently lead to better performance
for example number of designers very
little correlation with improved
performance
creating a shiny new design center very
little correlation with improved
performance
hiring a senior designer from from
another company
very little uh correlation improved
performance there were only four themes
that consistently made a difference and
we'll talk through
each of those in turn what i would say
before we cover each of those for though
mark is
the colleagues in singapore who have
already taken part
in this exercise have shared with us
that whilst the four that we're about to
talk about are common sense they're not
common practice
we originally asked over a hundred
companies in singapore
do you think that from a design point of
view you're in a good place
uh at the beginning of the interview
eighty percent of them said yes they
said yes i think we're doing things
right from a design point of view
when we actually benchmark them against
those 300 international companies
only 10 of those singaporean companies
were in the top and second quartile only
10
and what that means is a huge
opportunity here particularly for
singapore
to jump on these four themes and make a
real difference
those are certainly some super
insightful statistics
and that's certainly one of the reasons
why we saw value actually in the design
index
and it really kind of provides a
data-driven frame of reference when we
talk about design performance that
in the past has been rather abstract we
all may think that we are doing well in
design but it's actually important to
have a common language
and a point of reference to actually
identify areas of improvement and growth
yeah i fully agree with you and let's
talk about the the four i mean
the first one uh is is really around
leadership
um and this is one but we've had great
conversations with many many companies
in singapore
the marker of companies who are doing
well from a design leadership point of
view
are those who treat design
leadership with the same respect and
rigor that you might trip
treat strategy or or operations or or
any other more
uh mature uh leadership topic
they look at the data they make
decisions and
there's a ceo of um a med tech company
who
who said i thought in a very powerful
way he said if we don't have data
on the quality of our products on
whether it's leading to better patient
outcomes
better adherence to medication better
perceived quality of life and we have
that data to show we're doing markedly
better than a competition
than shame on us how can we be making
the right strategic decisions
unless we can be clear that our medical
device designs
are making a difference and a better
difference in others and that for me was
a really simple way of thinking about
how a ceo can think about design metrics
customer metrics patriot
patient metrics in a way that actually
leads to better strategic decisions
now the thing about creating additional
metrics and having these regular
assessments on user
outcomes sounds like it could be really
difficult for some organizations
and certainly appears so based on the
statistics from the results
what would you say to companies that
don't have the resources for this now
firstly don't panic you're in good
company and in fact in singapore of
the uh the leaders we spoke to 75
percent three out of four said they
currently don't feel they could make
objective business decisions on design
so
this is an area which is being developed
as we speak
i actually think the whole the whole
design industry is going through a bit
of a
renaissance at the moment this is like
what marketing went through in the 1990s
where it went from being this
black box this magic to people saying no
we can do
closed loop marketing we can look at roi
we can understand the metrics
and i think we're seeing that on the
metric side and design now
i'll give you one example of a company
who who i think
took this on really well and it was a
ceo of a consumer goods company who was
frustrated
that he felt that he and his top team
had lost connection with the customer
they felt that they didn't have the
right metrics
and they were just focused on pie charts
and ebitda but they'd lost that picture
on whether they actually had sustainably
better products and services
so what this individual did he walked
into his uh
his executive boardroom and he said to
his team
congratulations everybody i'm changing
your bonus
this year half your bonus will still be
tied to quarterly ebitda earnings of
course we have to deliver to the street
but the other half will be different on
christmas day
i will excuse myself from cutting the
turkey with my family
i will go and
see how our products are doing on amazon
not in terms of sales but in terms of
amazon stars out of five i'm gonna see
on average how many stars out of five
our products have
i'm gonna compare that to our leading
competition and if we have fewer stars
you don't get that second half of your
bonus am i clear
now you could say that's a very crass
measure you could say that's open to
to all sorts of gaming i'm sure everyone
opened an amazon account that night and
started
scoring things five but did it have the
intended consequence absolutely yes it
changed the culture of that company
people started talking about customers
it became a discussion in the boardroom
and i'd encourage companies in singapore
to think what's that equivalent
what's that one first customer-led
metric that they can bring to the
boardroom
that leads to a different kind of
conversation no absolutely i mean that's
a really interesting way of
getting people to focus holistically on
the customer
and really tying that to something
immediate and measurable right and just
really forcing a kind of cultural change
now that we've spoken actually about
these kind of concrete metrics what
about software aspects about
collaboration actually how teams work
together
that that was the second topic i mean
teamwork absolutely critical
we had an expectation though that the
companies that perform best were going
to be the ones who
created these wonderful design centers
these innovation centers
what we found from the research was
slightly counter-intuitively
companies who at some point seemed to
have made these huge ivory towers
committed to design actually saw a dip
in performance in the years that
followed
and what turned out to be important was
to some degree
de-emphasizing the importance of the
design department
but instead elevating the importance of
individual designers
and spending far more effort and energy
in thinking how do i effectively
integrate those designers into
cross-functional teams with engineering
with marketing
with product with finance with the
project management team as well
and it was those organizations those
institutions who were most successful
we saw this beautifully captured in a in
one company in fact it was a furniture
making company
who opened uh or planned
i should say to open a shiny design and
innovation center of two of its leading
markets
now in the second market they changed
their plan and instead they invested
that money in design
talent and better financial incentives
for those cross-functional teams
so that everyone in the team felt a
responsibility
for better products and services now if
you fast-forward five years
not only was that country where they had
gone away from the center and focused
more on the team
getting product to market 10 faster but
they were generating
30 percent higher revenue and the reason
is everyone in those teams whether
they're a designer or an engineer or
marketer
felt a true sense of responsibility and
accountability
for world-class design often we actually
hear
that many great user-centric projects
actually meet with bottlenecks
because of conflicts actually in
priorities across different departments
i
but we know there's always opportunities
to meaningfully engage
colleagues and staff to use design to
achieve
outcomes that actually has been one of
the areas um
of challenge that many of the companies
in singapore have brought up
many of them feel that they're not
testing and refining
uh their prototypes and their products
and services with end users enough in
fact sixty percent
of the hundred companies we spoke to in
singapore said they're not doing that
at a rate that they think is leading to
to improvements
and from the research that we did that
was actually the third theme so if
first and second themes are around
leadership and people the third one is
around
that iterative set of processes for
coming up
with better designs now we had an
expectation when we did this research
that uh
whether it be singapore or any nation
there might be certain tools and
techniques that people in
singapore should be using to do that
research and their design processes we
thought maybe
qualitative research would be better
than quantitative or we would find out
that
conjoint analysis was better than mac
stiff was better than in-home
uh video studies what we found from the
research
actually wasn't that there was no one
technique that companies can use
that consistently leads to finding
better user insights
but there was something around quantity
and there seems to be a magic mark
around the
the six different tools and techniques
companies who are using about three
different qualitative three different
quantitative
techniques to understand their users
were
improving uh their financial performance
dramatically faster
than companies who the process over
relied on
on just doing one sort of research with
end users
you know in singapore some of the
companies we spoke to have digital
products they said that's fine we can do
iteration we can do
uh iterative design but the companies
who have hardware
said iterative design doesn't work you
know at some point you need to buy
tooling at some point you need to invest
in
in a physical product i think one of the
interesting companies we we
came to know was uh st engineering they
have a
innovation unit called inno sparks right
and what they were doing is they were
recently working with
a outdoor cooling system with the
wildlife reserve
singapore company and they went through
multiple rounds of testing and
prototyping of the users and what we
found out was within 18 months
over 50 design iterations and systems
were built and tested
and that finally launched a successful
product and i think that's the sort of
spirit of what
we want more and more companies
understand what that looks like within
their own testing of products and
services for the market
i completely agree with you markets i
mean that that's such a
brilliant modern example 50 iterations
over 18 months in the engineering sector
you
know
the engineering sector gets a bad
reputation people used to think
engineering services you do it once as a
design phase and then that gets
locked and thrown towards launch two
years later comes successful failure
i think that's an example of a company
that's seen the light so congratulations
to
th there's one final theme i think you
and i should talk about before we
we sort of close on on the actions and
the fourth and final theme is in some
ways the easiest to describe but the
hardest to do
so once you've got your great leadership
once you've got your perfect team once
they're doing a modern design process
the final piece to break here is around
fixing the silos between physical
digital
and service design there are so many
companies now who still have a separate
physical design
arm a separate digital arm and it really
gets in the way
of modern seamless experience that
customers have become to
expect um you know if i think of some of
the examples that stick with me
there was an example of a med tech
company
who was making products for people with
chronic disease
the way they used to think about that is
well we're a physical product company
so we need to think about viscosity we
need to think about the volume to be
injected into the body
of this particular medicine and what
they did is say that that's a very
old-fashioned way of thinking about our
industry
let's instead for a moment think about
the combination
of digital physical and service in the
form of doctors and nurses
and they started talking instead of
about a physical injection device
they started talking about reminders
that you're sick
and in fact in this particular disease
many people had about 27 reminders
uh in a given month that they were a
sick individual that they were living
under the burden of this disease
and what the company did is they said no
well let's work together to reduce that
burden
they got it from 27 reminders down to
seven
uh nine reminders sorry that you were
sick and that's when you started to have
improved patient quality of life that's
when you started to have
improved medical outcomes and that was
brilliant the fact that this company
moved from thinking about product
thinking about product and
apps and in-person services i think that
the recognition that user experience is
critical is actually becoming more
commonplace i i do believe that
we're actually seeing more companies
focus on a kind of holistic user
experience journey
and more than just optimizing as kind of
single touch point
for me one one example close to heart is
our local airport changi airport
as an example they've actually we've
talked to the team and they actually
conduct meticulous research to actually
stitch the traveler's journey
together to ultimately create a seamless
and delightful way of balancing
they call kind of hospitality and a
transportation efficiency
and i think one large thing one large
innovation they did a lot of the last
few years was to build this
uh huge kind of uh centerpiece called
jewel
to be able to complete the kind of
airport experience to wild visitors
so i totally agree with you no i'm
with you all i and i hope to be able to
uh to see jewel
uh soon and be with you mark in
singapore when you and i last went it
was a few months from completion and i'm
i'm sad that the world has changed so
much but i haven't been back since but
uh hopefully 2021 will be the uh
will be the year um i'm really excited
about what follows in today's
conversation i think that
the themes that we've touched on whether
it be the things like that breakdown of
physical and digital service like you
you're mentioning at the airport
whether it be the leadership piece
whether it be the people piece
whether it be the process piece i think
all of these sort of common sense i
think these are all things that
companies in singapore can do
i think for me it feels a little bit
like diet and exercise we all know we're
supposed to be doing it but none of us
do it
and i what i hope is today comes
something of a
a catalyst moment where many companies
can say actually no we can do these four
together
and i think we'll see a real difference
in the in the months and years that
follow in terms of performance
thanks for reminding me i do need to die
on an exercise in 2021
but these are certainly exciting results
it gives us
personally a kind of clearer picture
about how we at design singapore can
actually help further support companies
to grow to the next level